patrimoine découvertes rencontres
évasion c'est aussi votre rayon
dominique bruillot un peu ah oui
beaucoup même et puis passionnément à la
folie quand il s'agit de nuits saint
georges au lendemain d'une vente des
vins pas comme les autres voilà pourquoi
vous avez choisi de parler de mes
saint-georges aujourd'hui j'ai voulu
remettre l'église au milieu du village
et la lune au milieu de nuits saint
georges
tout simplement parce qu'on a parlé
d'une vente aux enchères cette année il
comme un rien ne se passait autour voilà
j'avais souhaité c'est le coup
comprendre nuits saint georges en cinq
images oui d'autant que le parrain de
cette édition est un grand amateur des
bourgognes c'est erik orsenna donc voilà
un monsieur comme vous dites à propos de
monsieur si je vous dit henri gouges où
justement le papa with un des papas de
l'appellation l'homme des origines est
un pas que reçut alors le voilà alors
ils bougent en famille de vignerons
depuis plusieurs siècles
et puis henri gauche était un des
pionniers du terroir il avait compris
avant tout le monde qu'il fallait donner
comment dire il fallait définir le
terroir et les télécréateurs en 1928
huit ans avant la création de de
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée de ce
qu'on appelle l'authenticité garantie on
retrouve encore les vieilles bouteilles
avec ce ce logo fins ce label qui a été
précurseur de lille à la naissance de
l'inao sera d'ailleurs un des papas
ligne à où un reconnu en tant que tel et
c'était un très fondateur on reste à
nuits-saint-georges pascal michel
jeanjean sait faire la fête avec la
reine des nuits si j'ose dire oui la ld
lui alors voilà je connais celle d'un
bon l'avait quelque chose oui elle m'a
dit qu'elle pense jose je ne dirais pas
l'année parce que ça serait lui faire
offense
mais en tout cas il ya toujours eu des
traditions festives à nuits saint
georges
n'oublions pas que nuits saint georges
était le berceau de la confrérie des
chevaliers du tastevin que en pleine
crise un parallèle à faire avec
aujourd'hui on a décidé de faire la fête
pour sauver le levain qui à l'époque ne
vendez pas beaucoup alors lui saint
georges
ça a été long temps réel des rennes on
espère que ça va revenir les rênes de
nuit et non pas les reines de la nuit
mais nous on est preneur avec vincent
pour la reine de la pop
on va tous y aller dès que les
conditions sanitaires nous le
permettront je suis une petite
parenthèse parce que c'est aussi à
nuits-saint-georges qu'on célèbre le vin
bourru et sympa parce qu'elle arrive de
l'opposition et l'opinion et les
franc-comtois qui vont très
régulièrement là bas vous parlions de
lune tout à l'heure à l'est on se pose
avec apollo 15 en est en juillet 71
qu'est ce qui sépare histoire est drôle
c'est parce que déjà jules verne avait
mis une bouteille de nuits saint georges
dans les mains de ses héros comme dans
le dans le livre de la terre à la lune
et puis
pommier que lui saint georges c'est
aussi la ville de félix tisserand que
d'un grand astronome tenté c'est bien
que félix tisserand a donné son nom à un
cratère est beaucoup plus tard les
astronautes d'apollo 15 passes par le
clos vougeot d une discussion avec eux
le m
le maître du groupe clos vougeot le
grand maître barbier le le descendant de
jules verne qui étaient là et les six
stades dans la main et disant on va
mettre les nuits saint georges sur la
lune alors on pouvait pas mettre une
bouteille trop lourd trop président
une cuvée terre-lune a été créé pour ça
et c'est une étiquette de cette cuvée
qui était posée sur un cratère parfait
on salue l'astronaute david scott aussi
à 502,7 alunissage le 31 juillet de
cette année allez on se pose avec jean
marie mauron aussi parce que voilà ça
fait partie de ces personnages célèbres
qui apporte beaucoup à
nuits-saint-georges énormément puisque
je pense que sans sans les hospices de
nuits nuit il aura plus de dire
d'établissements hospitaliers y apporte
chance puisque c'est la vente aux
enchères qui a permis de financer le
nouvel établissement hospitalier et en
même temps si cette vente est aussi
connue c'est parce que elle a quelqu'un
à sa tête s'appelle monsieur moreau jean
donc gens voilà qui est un qui est un
régisseur très ouverte et très reconnue
et qui fait des vins splendide justement
jean des mois il ya précieux nectar à
consommer évidemment avec modération je
parle sur les studios europe acteurs à
bascons va pas boire alors une science
détrompera xi par excès il faut pas
c'est par un comment l'elysée c'est pas
en commander en revanche on peut aussi
un grand cru tant qu'à faire à nuits
saint georges avec modération pour
terminer que le saint georges
oui de toute façon lui saint-georges
aurait mérité son grand cru oui sur
l'étiquette la mention saint georges
saint georges a été rajoutée au nom de
lewis théoriquement et aurait dû avoir
son grand cru depuis longtemps mais
henri gourgeon on y revient elle était
propriétaire de saint-georges et n'a pas
évolué comment dire faire profiter de
son sa prestance de sa position à l'inao
pour le transformer en grands crus mais
c'est à l'ordre du jour à nouveau lui
serge rassemble de son grand cru le
saint-georges bientôt et bien on en
reparlera avec deux minutes pour mieux
je ne doute pas que vous puissiez en
reparler d'embrouillés de magazines et
que dans coeur de contrôle facile et
coups de paul valtra le mba paix de la
charcutaille sol et montrer tout à
l'heure sympathiquement avec vous on
dirait que j'aime beaucoup en tout cas
voilà notre grande région réunis dans
coeur de comtois et bourgogne magazine